I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hello, hello, everybody. Lady, we're sort of dressed the same.
We're dressed the same and we're both recording from our home offices today.
And black t-shirts.
And black classes.
Did you put any makeup on today?
Do I look like it?
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，更深入地探索办公室的世界。我们是办公室女郎 6.0。大家好，大家好。女郎，我们今天穿得有点像。我们穿得一样，而且我们今天都是在家里的办公室进行录制的。还有黑色T恤。还有黑色眼镜。你今天化妆了吗？我看起来像化了吗？
Did you do your hair?
This is day two hair because I had like kind of a fun job yesterday.
Yeah.
So your hair looks good.
Thank you.
So yeah, I didn't make any other effort.
And then I have day two hair.
你弄头发了吗？这是头发的第二天，因为我昨天有一份挺有趣的工作。对。所以你的头发看起来不错。谢谢。谢谢。所以，是的，我没有做任何其他努力。然后我有第二天的头发。
I mean, for me, I've always felt like if my hair looks good, that's more important than putting on makeup.
for me.
For sure, for sure.
Which is why I'm so very excited to have hair again.
I have a full bob now.
You do, and it's so cute and sassy.
I love it.
I think I'm going to grow up two or three more inches,
我的意思是，对我来说，我一直觉得如果我的头发看起来不错，那比化妆更重要。对我来说。确实，确实。这就是为什么我很高兴能再次拥有头发。我现在有一个完整的波波头。你确实有，而且它太可爱、太时髦了。我很喜欢它。我想我还要再留长两三英寸，
just where it just brushes the shoulder.
You know, I cut three inches off my hair.
Sorry, guys, this is a lot of talk about haircuts and whatnot,
but I mean, I like a summer trim.
Same.
I know we're talking a lot about hair right now,
but it is 98 degrees out today.
It is so hot.
刚好垂到肩膀的长度。你知道，我把头发剪短了三英寸。抱歉，各位，这里有很多关于理发之类的话题，但我的意思是，我喜欢夏天修剪头发。我也是。我知道我们现在在谈论很多关于头发的事情，但今天外面有98华氏度。天气太热了。
And yet we are casual.
We are casual today.
Look at you, go.
You're working in our episode.
Did you like that?
I did like it.
So why don't we share with everyone what we're doing today?
然而我们很随性。我们今天很随性。看你，去吧。你在演我们的剧集。你喜欢那个吗？你喜欢那个吗？我确实喜欢。那我们为什么不和大家分享一下我们今天在做什么呢？
Well, this episode was inspired by some mail we got in our second drink folder,
specifically about the episode, Casual Friday from Season 5.
and it kind of got us investigating this episode again,
and there was so much we wanted to discuss.
It was too much for a second drink,
so today we're bringing it to 6.0, and we're going to dive in.
We are, you guys, we went into the scripts, the candy bag alts,
and we're also going to discuss the new scenes that were added to the superfan.
嗯，这一集是受到我们收到的信件的启发，在我们第二个饮品文件夹里，具体是关于第五季的《休闲星期五》那一集。这让我们再次调查这一集，有太多我们想要讨论的事情。对于第二杯来说太多了，所以今天我们把它带到了 6.0 版，我们要深入探讨。是的，伙计们，我们研究了剧本、糖果包的备选方案，我们还将讨论添加到超级粉丝版中的新场景。
Here's the beautiful thing about the office, you guys.
Each time I rewatch it, and I know you guys listening out there, do this too,
I feel like I discover something new.
And let me tell you, I loved our original breakdown of this episode. It's a really good one.
If you want to listen to something on a road trip or a slow day at work. I mean, Brian Baumgartner comes on.
He talks about that famous chilly cold open. We also talked with Randy Cordray, our producer, our costume designer, Alicia Raycraft.
Kate Flannery, I mean, we really dug in.
But also, we got info from Creed Bratton, from John Krasinski, and from director Brent Forrester.
办公室最美妙的地方在于，伙计们。每次我重温它，我知道你们这些在外面听的人，也这样做，我觉得我发现了新东西。让我告诉你，我很喜欢我们对这一集的最初剖析。这是一个非常好的剖析。如果你想在公路旅行或工作清闲的日子里听点什么。我的意思是，布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳上节目了。他谈到了那个著名的辣椒冷开场。我们还与我们的制片人兰迪·科德雷、我们的服装设计师艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫进行了交谈。凯特·弗兰纳里，我的意思是，我们真的深入探讨了。但是我们也从克里德·布拉顿、约翰·卡拉辛斯基和导演布伦特·福斯特那里得到了信息。
It is a stacked episode.
And yet, if you can believe it, we have even more to discuss today.
But first, I think we should do our chit-chat question.
It was sent in by Freya N in Phoenixville, Pennsylvania.
Hey, office ladies.
My name is Freya.
And I was wondering, because you guys talk a lot about food and snacking on the podcast.
So I'm interested to know what is your perfect?
这是一集内容丰富的剧集。然而，如果你能相信的话，我们今天还有更多要讨论的内容。但首先，我想我们应该做我们的闲聊问题。它是弗雷娅·N发来的，来自宾夕法尼亚州菲尼克斯ville。嘿，办公室女郎。我叫弗雷娅。我想知道，因为你们在播客中经常谈论食物和零食。所以我很有兴趣知道什么是你完美的？
food day like breakfast, lunch, dinner, dessert. You can eat anything. You can fly anywhere in the world.
Unlimited amount of money. Calories don't count. No allergies. Yeah, so anything goes. But yeah,
I'm just curious to know what would be your perfect food day. Like what would you be eating for
breakfast, lunch, dinner, and dessert. Again, I love your podcast, and I hope you continue to do this
for many, many years to come. Thank you. Bye. Oh, Freya, I would need to start by saying I feel so
seen by you. Particularly because you mentioned our love of snacks as well as all food. And lady,
I have a new snack. What? You're coming in hot. I'm sorry. Okay, you know I love like cheddar,
sort of things. You know, you know this. Oh, I know this. You know, I ate those Trader Joe's cheddar crackers by like the box load.
食物日，比如早餐、午餐、晚餐、甜点。你可以吃任何东西。你可以飞往世界上的任何地方。无限量的金钱。卡路里不算。没有过敏。是的，所以任何东西都可以。但是的，我只是好奇想知道你完美的一天饮食是什么样的。比如你会吃早餐、午餐、晚餐和甜点。再次，我喜欢你的播客，我希望你继续这样做很多很多年。谢谢。再见。哦，弗雷娅，我首先需要说的是，我觉得你非常懂我。特别是你提到了我们对零食以及所有食物的热爱。而且女郎，我有一个新零食。什么？你来势汹汹。我很抱歉。好吧，你知道我喜欢切达干酪之类的东西。你知道的，你知道这个。哦，我知道这个。你知道，我吃那些Trader Joe's的切达干酪饼干就像吃一箱一样。
I've seen you eat like half a box. Yeah. And then after that, I got super obsessed with tanner bunnies. Yes. I have a new one. Okay. Okay. I discovered them when I was in Chicago and I can't stop. They are Simple Mills, almond flour, farmhouse cheddar crackers.
And it's the texture. It's the way, like, when you eat it is so good.
Okay. I'm sold. I'll try it.
Well, Freya, my first answer to your question is my snack would be cheddar crackers.
My snack is still and has been for decades, a cheese stick and some pretzels.
And we all know I chomp, I don't pull the string. Okay, let's get over it.
Okay. Well, what is our perfect food day?
Where are we having breakfast, lunch, dinner, and dessert, no limitation.
我见你吃过半盒。是的。然后在那之后，我对tanner bunnies超级着迷。是的。我有一个新的。好的。我在芝加哥时发现了它们，我停不下来。它们是Simple Mills杏仁粉农舍切达干酪饼干。这就是质感。这就是那种，当你吃它的时候太棒了。好的。我买了。我试试。好吧，弗雷娅，我对你问题的第一个回答是我的零食将是切达干酪饼干。我的零食仍然是而且几十年来一直是奶酪棒和一些饼干。我们都知道我大口咀嚼，我不拉那根线。好吧，让我们过去吧。好的。好吧，我们完美的一天饮食是什么？我们在哪里吃早餐、午餐、晚餐和甜点，没有限制。
Lee and I play this game sometimes. It's really fun. What are we going to do? Let's go back and forth. You say breakfast. I say breakfast. Go back and forth. Okay. I want to go to France for breakfast.
Ooh, la, la. Oh, because that's right. Fray said we could go wherever. Yes. So I want to go to France and I want to have like a single awesome like French press coffee. I want to have some musli with some like fresh, fresh yogurt. And I want to have some delicious pastries. Okay. You know, I'm not.
huge breakfast eater. You know this. But I love Josh's homemade granola. I do. And my favorite thing is
to eat his granola and I take some bananas and I chop them up and I have peanut butter and honey
and Josh's granola and I kind of mix it all together. That's one of my favorite breakfast.
Okay. I like that answer. Okay. Lunch. I've shared about this before on the podcast.
I want to go back to Tokyo and go to the Shibuya Food Show.
and maybe just have some chicken ramen or a bento box.
李和我有时会玩这个游戏。这真的很有趣。我们要怎么做？我们来回说。你说了早餐。我说早餐。来回说。好的。我想去法国吃早餐。哇，啦，啦。哦，因为那是对的。弗雷说我们可以去任何地方。是的。所以我想去法国，我想喝一杯单人超棒的法压咖啡。我想吃一些麦片配一些新鲜、新鲜的酸奶。我想吃一些美味的糕点。好的。你知道的，我不是。个大胃王早餐吃。你知道的。但我喜欢乔什的自制麦片。我确实喜欢。我最喜欢的事是吃他的麦片，我拿一些香蕉把它们切碎，我有花生酱和蜂蜜和乔什的麦片，我把它们混合在一起。这是我最喜欢的早餐之一。好的。我喜欢那个答案。好的。午餐。我以前在播客里分享过这个。我想回到东京去涩谷食品展。也许只吃一些鸡肉拉面或便当盒。
But I'm going to Japan for lunch.
Okay.
I love lunch.
It's like one of my favorite things if you get to splurge and go out for lunch, you know?
Because I feel like I'm always just having a sandwich at home.
So if I get to go out, oh, you know what I love?
What?
但我要去日本吃午餐。好的。好的。我喜欢午餐。这就像我最喜欢的事情之一，如果你能挥霍一下出去吃午餐，你知道吗？因为我觉得我总是在家里吃三明治。所以如果我能出去，哦，你知道我喜欢什么吗？什么？
I love just like a little mom and pop like Mexican food place.
Like there's one in the valley here in Los Angeles called Tony's Mexican Grill.
And I love their lunch combos like a cheese enchilada, a crispy shell taco, a tamale.
That is like one of the best lunches.
Okay.
Dinner.
我只喜欢像一个小型夫妻店那样的墨西哥餐馆。比如在洛杉矶的山谷里有一家叫托尼墨西哥烧烤店。我喜欢他们的午餐组合，比如奶酪安吉拉卷、脆皮墨西哥玉米饼、玉米粉蒸肉。那是最好的午餐之一。好的。好的。晚餐。晚餐。
I'm going far for dinner, lady.
Where are you going? Where are you going? I want to take you guys to Singapore. You guys know I grew up in Indonesia. We'd go to Singapore a lot. Listen, you need to go to a hawker center. I've been to Laupasot. There's a bunch. But it is a culinary experience, Jenna. It is amazing. Like there's just about every type of food that you would want to try. I mean, there's a street called saute street. And you can get different types of saute.
Wow. Lady. Lady. Lady. It is truly.
such a cool experience and the food is so good. And by the way, it's open all day. So if you wanted to do
breakfast and lunch there, you could. But I would take you there for dinner. We'd get some Nasi-Goring,
some really good fried rice, some chicken saute. There's, oh my goodness, like you could be there for
hours. That sounds amazing. Okay. I like that. Okay. What about you? What about you?
For dinner? Mm-hmm. I don't know. I love Indian food. Oh, you really do.
为了晚餐我要走得很远，女士。你要去哪里？你要去哪里？我想带你们去新加坡。你们知道我在印度尼西亚长大。我们经常去新加坡。听着，你需要去一个小贩中心。我去过老巴刹。有很多。但这是一种烹饪体验，珍娜。太棒了。就像几乎有你想尝试的每一种食物。我的意思是，有一条街叫沙爹街。你可以买到不同种类的沙爹。哇。女郎。女郎。女郎。这真的是。一个很酷的体验，食物太棒了。顺便说一句，它一整天都开着。所以如果你想在那里吃早餐和午餐，你可以。但我会带你去那里吃晚餐。我们会得到一些印尼炒饭，一些非常好的炒饭，一些鸡肉沙爹。有，哦，天哪，就像你可以在那里呆上几个小时一样。听起来太棒了。好的。我喜欢那个。好的。你呢？你呢？晚餐？嗯-hmm。我不知道。我喜欢印度菜。哦，你真的很喜欢。
I love Italian food. I love a smash burger. I love a smash.
Burger. Can I leave dinner open for like, what am I feeling? Those would be my three things. I'm having
one of those three things for dinner. Frea, we are clearly very passionate about this question.
It's like our brains are breaking over it. A little bit. But I know my dessert, hardcore,
I want a delicious strawberry and rhubarb pie with a nice scoop of vanilla ice cream.
Well, one of my favorite all-time desserts is a chocolate meringue pie. My mom made them
for me growing up. Now, Josh makes it for me. I get one every year on my birthday, and I will fight you
if you come for my chocolate meringue pie, I'll be like, hey, like, I think I've told you this lady.
我喜欢意大利菜。我喜欢汉堡。我喜欢一个汉堡。我可以把晚餐留给像，我的感觉是什么？那将是我的三件事。我要吃这三样东西中的一样当晚餐。弗雷娅，我们对这个问题显然非常热情。就像我们的大脑为此崩溃了一样。有一点。但我知道我的甜点，坚定不移地，我想要一个美味的草莓大黄派配上一勺香草冰激淋。嗯，我一直以来最喜欢的甜点之一是巧克力蛋白酥皮派。我妈妈在我长大时为我做这些。现在，乔什为我做。我每年生日都会得到一个，如果你来抢我的巧克力蛋白酥皮派，我会跟你拼命，我会说，嘿，就像，我想我告诉过你这个女郎。
Josh's friend, Devin was over. And Josh was like, hey, Devin wants a piece of pie. And I'm like,
not a big piece. I'm like, pulled him aside. I was like, just give him a little slice.
That's very funny. Yeah. And, you know, for me, strawberry rhubarb pie is the one thing I will not bake
myself because rhubarb is such a high maintenance thing. It's time consuming and I've never cooked
it. I've never made it. But if I'm anywhere and I see rubarb on a menu, I'm ordering it.
You're all about it. I love it. I get so excited. Well, there you go, Freya. Thank you so much for
sending in that question. Yeah. I'm hungry now. I'm hungry. I'm realizing I don't have any of those
crackers and I'm going to have to put them on the shopping list for later today. Send me a link.
乔什的朋友德文过来了。乔什说，嘿，德文想吃一块派。我说，不要大块。我说，把他拉到一边。我说，只给他切一小片。这太有趣了。是的，而且，对我来说，草莓大黄派是我唯一不会自己烤的东西，因为大黄是一件需要高维护的事情。这很耗时，我从来没有煮过它。我从来没有做过。但如果我在任何地方看到菜单上有大黄，我就会点它。你全心全意。我喜欢它。我太兴奋了。好吧，就是这样，弗雷娅。非常感谢你发来那个问题。是的。我现在饿了。我饿了。我意识到我没有任何那些饼干，我将不得不把它们放在今天晚上的购物清单上。发给我一个链接。
I want to get some. All right. Oh, I'll bring him into the studio next time we're in studio.
Okay. All right. Well, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we're going to dive into
casual Friday. I have some fun digital clutter shares. And I also found something hilarious
online I want to talk about. Oh, yay. I can't wait. Well, welcome back. Let's dive into some
casual Friday. And why don't we start with? Wait for it. It's been a while, guys. But I'm going to
going to my digital clutter.
I'm very excited for this. I don't know what this is.
I know you don't. I was looking through my old emails to see if you and I had exchanged any
我想买一些。好的。哦，下次我们在录音室的时候我会带到录音室。好的。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？当我们回来时，我们将深入探讨休闲星期五。我有一些有趣的数字杂乱分享。我还想讨论我在网上发现的一件极其搞笑的事情。哦，耶。我等不及了。好吧，欢迎回来。让我们深入了解一些休闲星期五。我们为什么不从……开始呢？等一下。已经有一段时间了，伙计们。但我将去整理我的数字杂乱。我对此非常兴奋。我不知道这是什么。我知道你不知道。我翻看我的旧邮件，看看你和我是否交换过任何
while we were filming this episode, and I found something that really cracked me up.
Okay. So here's what we were doing during this time in our lives.
Okay.
This email happened right after we filmed Casual Friday. I guess we were just starting company
picnic, right? And there were lots of festivities going on for that 100th episode of the office, right?
Yeah.
Including a party.
And we talked a little bit about this before, you know, when the 100th episode of the office came around and company picnic.
在我们拍摄这一集的时候，我发现了一些让我真正大笑的事情。好的。所以我们在生活中的这个时候在做这个。好的。这封电子邮件发生在我们在《休闲星期五》之后。我想我们刚刚开始《公司野餐》，对吧？为了《办公室》的第100集，有很多庆祝活动正在进行，对吧？是的，包括一个派对。我们之前稍微谈过这个，你知道的，当《办公室》的第100集到来时和《公司野餐》。
But I did not share this email that I found.
And I'm going to read it to you.
Okay.
This is April 19, 2009, 231 a.m.
What?
From Jenna Fisher to Angela Kinsey.
I can't believe I was awake at that time, any time in my life.
subject title semicolon toilet what is this and then this is what the body of the email says
但我没有分享我找到的这封邮件。我要读给你听。好的。这是2009年4月19日凌晨2点31分。什么？从珍娜·费舍尔到安吉拉·金西。我不敢相信我在那个时间醒着，我生命中的任何时间。主题标题分号厕所这是什么然后这就是邮件正文所说的话
yep i'm on the toilet i figured this was easier than texting and it is keeping me occupied as i deal with
whatever is wrong with me oh my god ugh i'm just praying
it isn't the flu, but if it is, I am profoundly grateful that it didn't hit three days ago
or something, because I think that's while we were filming.
Okay.
You go on to say, I wish I had good gossip from the party.
My favorite conversation was with Jeff Blitz and Jen Salada.
I told them the story of how you wrote, quote, water on your water bottle instead of
是的，我在马桶上。我想这比发短信容易，而且它可以让我专注于处理我身上的任何毛病。哦，天哪，呃，我只是祈祷这不是流感，但如果是的话，我深深地感激它没有在三天前左右发作，因为我想那是在我们拍摄的时候。好的。你接着说，我希望我有派对上的好八卦。我最喜欢的对话是与杰夫·布里茨和詹·萨拉达。我告诉他们你是如何在睡眠不足生完孩子后，在水瓶上写下“水”而不是
your name when you were sleep deprived after having the baby.
Jen said one time when they passed the Starbucks order sheet, she wrote that she wanted
and Andy talking head because she was so wiped.
They also made a 100 moments montage.
I really wish you could have been there.
Okay, I'm heading to bed now.
I'm not feeling so hot.
Now I want to throw up.
你的名字的故事。詹说，有一次他们传递星巴克点单表时，她写下她想要一个安迪访谈镜头，因为她太累了。他们还制作了一个100个瞬间的蒙太奇。我真的很希望你能去。好的，我这就去睡觉了。我感觉不太好。现在我想吐。
Talk tomorrow.
Hope this passes, Jenna.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, lady, my response.
7.44 a.m.
Same day.
Ug lady, so sorry.
Definitely just take care of yourself.
明天聊。希望这能过去，珍娜。哦，天哪。好吧，女郎，我的回复。早上7点44分。同一天。呃，女郎，太遗憾了。一定要照顾好自己。
I am bummed that I was.
wasn't there to celebrate our 100 Epps, but honestly, my night here was great. I'm glad my
sitter bailed. I was so happy to be with my little gal. Right now, Isabel and I are eating
Cheerios and watching Dolphins jump. I get why people live by the beach. I hope you feel better.
Sent via Blackberry by AT&T. And that is because I had rented a little place near where we were
filming company picnic because I didn't want Isabel to be in a car seat for an hour. And I wanted her to be
with me because I didn't work every day. I'm not in that episode a ton, you know? So I made it like a little
mini vacay. And yeah, I guess I had a babysitter that bailed so I didn't get to go. You did have a
我很遗憾我。不在那里庆祝我们的100集，老实说，我这里的夜晚很棒。我很高兴我的保姆放了鸽子。我很高兴能和我的小女孩在一起。现在，伊莎贝尔和我正在吃谷物圈麦片看海豚跳跃。我明白了为什么人们住在海滩旁。希望你感觉好点。由黑莓通过AT&T发送。那是因为我在我们拍摄《公司野餐》附近租了一个小地方，因为我不想让伊莎贝尔在一个小时的车程里坐儿童安全座椅。我希望她能和我在一起，因为我不是每天都工作。我那一集里戏份不多，你知道吗？所以我把它当成了一个小小的迷你假期。是的，我想我有一个保姆放了鸽子，所以我没去。你确实有一个
follow-up email lady that said, thank God I'm feeling better. Oh, and one other thing from the party,
I watched a certain someone hit on a bunch of women and one other person dirty dance up on their
boyfriend. I'm not going to mention names.
I've got good digital clutter, lady.
Lady, you know, it's like I want you to have less emails in your inbox, but I love your
digital clutter share so much.
Please never clean out your inbox, please.
When I found this for everyone listening, I left Jonah a message and I was like, you will
后续邮件，女士，上面写着，谢天神我感觉好多了。哦，还有派对上的另一件事，我看到某人在调戏一群女性，另一个人在他们的男友身上大跳热舞。我不打算提名字。我有很多数字杂乱，女士。女士，你知道，这就像我希望你的收件箱里有更少的电子邮件，但我太喜欢你的数字杂乱分享了。请永远不要清理你的收件箱，求你了。当我为所有听众发现这一点时，我给乔娜留言说，你会
not believe what I'm reading in my email right now.
It's bringing me such joy.
All right.
Well, that was a great kickoff.
I have some trivia that I found in my digital clutter.
It's not nearly as good as that,
but I did find out that the original title for Casual Friday was Office Reunited.
Huh.
不会相信我现在在邮件里读到的东西。这给我带来了极大的快乐。好吧，那是一个很好的开端。我在我的数字杂乱中发现了一些冷知识。它远不如那个好，但我确实发现《休闲星期五》的最初标题是《办公室重聚》。哈。
I mean, I think Casual Friday is such a more zippy title, don't you?
It is.
But I mean, you know, this episode is where Michael, Pam, and Ryan come back from working at Michael Scott Paper Company.
So it is like, you know.
That would describe what was happening.
Yeah.
But Casual Friday.
我的意思是，我认为《休闲星期五》是一个更有活力的标题，不是吗？是的。但我的意思是，你知道，这一集是迈克尔、帕姆和瑞安从迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司工作回来的时候。所以这就像，你知道的。这会描述正在发生的事情。是的。是的。但《休闲星期五》。
a far superior title, yes.
Okay, well, this episode opens with that famous Kevin Chilly scene, right?
We talked about it a lot on the podcast.
Like we said, in our original breakdown, Brian actually talks all about it.
And we also discuss it with Aaron Scher, who wrote it.
But I have some new trivia for you.
Oh.
Yeah.
一个远为出色的标题，是的。好吧，这一集以著名的凯文辣椒场景开场，对吧？我们在播客中谈了很多关于它的内容。正如我们所说，在我们最初的剖析中，布赖恩实际上谈到了这一切。我们还与撰写它的亚伦·舍尔进行了讨论。但我有一些新的冷知识给你。哦。是的。
It's about that scene, and it's thanks to a letter from Michael B in Lebanon, Pennsylvania.
Michael says, I just acquired some of Pam's items that NBC auctioned off from her death.
Some of the papers were, quote, Dunder Mifflin accounting actuals, which I believe are actually just lists of
some of Phil Shea's prop purchases, but printed on Dunder Mifflin letterhead.
For this episode, it lists that three, quote, aged chili pots were purchased from a company named
Studio Art and Technology for $163.88.
Oh my gosh.
Isn't that wild?
它是关于那个场景的，这要感谢来自宾夕法尼亚州黎巴嫩的迈克尔·B的一封信。迈克尔说，我刚刚获得了NBC拍卖的帕姆的一些物品。其中一些纸是，“Dunder Mifflin会计实际明细”，我认为这实际上只是菲尔·谢伊的一些道具购买清单，但印有Dunder Mifflin的信头。对于这一集，它列出了从一家名为Studio Art and Technology的公司购买了三个，“陈年辣椒罐”，价格为163.88美元。哦，天哪。是不是很疯狂？
Wow.
Wow, that is a really cool keepsake.
I know, and you know, Phil would do that, right?
He would take just like, I mean, office papers, even from our own production office, and use them as props on the set.
Yeah.
Oh, that's neat.
Yeah, I thought so, too.
Thanks for writing in, Michael.
哇。哇，这是一个非常酷的纪念品。我知道，你知道，菲尔会那样做，对吧？他会带走就像，我的意思是，办公室的纸张，甚至来自我们自己的制作办公室的纸张，并用作片场道具。是的。哦，太棒了。是的，我也这么觉得。谢谢你写信来，迈克尔。
Well, I've got a little background catch, a new one.
Okay.
It's at two minutes and 16 seconds.
It's in that conference room scene that opens the episode.
I did not notice this before.
but Creed has his eyes closed.
And I wondered, was this a forgotten storyline?
Like, why are his eyes closed?
好吧，我有一个小背景花絮，一个新的。好的。在2分16秒。它在开场的那个会议室场景中。我之前没有注意到这一点。但克里德闭着眼睛。我想知道，这是一个被遗忘的故事情节吗？为什么他闭着眼睛？
Yeah, I saw that too.
And some folks had commented on that.
And I couldn't find anything in the scripts about that.
But I took a screen grab of that moment.
And I texted it to Creed and I said,
Creed, are you pretending to meditate in this moment?
I mean, it is casual Friday.
He looks like he's dressed in some type of yoga slash spa retreat outfit.
是的，我也看到了。有些人对此发表了评论。我在剧本中找不到任何关于这方面的内容。但我截取了那一刻的屏幕截图。我把它发给克里德，我说，克里德，你在这个时刻是在假装冥想吗？我的意思是，今天是休闲星期五。他看起来穿着某种瑜伽或水疗静修服。
Creed wrote back, well, I don't know, but that sounds as good a reason as any. I think meditation
sounds right. And then I wrote back, ha, well, I'm convinced that was your acting choice.
And he wrote back and said, meth it all the way, pumpkin. Yeah. It wasn't in the script.
I checked the script to see if there was something that says, like, Creed is going to spend the day
meditating or something. I think that was his added little layer. Yeah, Creed thinks so too. Well,
also got this letter from a listener in Santa Clarita, California. Evelyn R. said,
Hey, ladies, I'm a long-time listener, and now I have my husband hooked on your podcast.
I love this episode and was curious what the script said about everyone's casual
Creed 回信说，嗯，我不知道，但这理由听起来跟别的差不多。我觉得冥想听起来挺对的。然后我回信说，哈哈，好吧，我确信那是你的演技选择。他回信说，完全是毒品，南瓜。是的。剧本里本来没有。我查了剧本，看看里面有没有写着像“克里德今天要花一整天时间冥想”之类的内容。我觉得那是他自己加的小细节。对，克里德也这么觉得。嗯，另外还收到了一位来自加利福尼亚州圣克拉里塔的听众的信。伊芙琳·R（Evelyn R.）说，嘿，女士们，我是你们的老听众了，现在我还让我丈夫也迷上了你们的播客。我很喜欢这一集，很好奇剧本里对大家的随意
Friday outfits. How were they described? And you know what, Jenna, I realized I didn't do a
costume breakdown for Casual Friday. What? I know. You're right. I always do those.
You always do them. I know. Well, Evelyn, I went to our shooting draft. I was. I went to our shooting draft.
and I found some amazing tidbits.
In answer to your question,
here's what it said in the script
about what people were wearing
in that first conference room scene.
周五服装是怎么说的。它们是怎么被描述的呢？你知道吗，珍娜，我意识到我没有为“随意星期五”做一个服装盘点。什么？我知道。你说得对。我总是做那些。你总是做那些。我知道。好吧，伊芙琳，我看了我们的拍摄剧本。我……我看了我们的拍摄剧本，发现了一些精彩的趣闻。回答你的问题，剧本里是这样描述大家在第一个会议室场景中穿的衣服的：
It said,
Interior conference room.
Everyone is there.
People are dressed in casual attire.
Stanley in a T-shirt.
Oscar in a windbreaker in jeans.
Kelly in a jumpsuit.
Dwight wears the same outfit as usual
上面写着，内景会议室。所有人都在。人们穿着休闲服装。斯坦利穿着T恤。奥斯卡穿着防风夹克和牛仔裤。凯莉穿着连体裤。德怀特穿着和平时一样的衣服
but with no tie.
Andy is wearing a shirt that says
Ben, Dover,
you.
and on the back, apply within, with an arrow pointing to his butt.
Okay.
So it's very interesting that the script said that about Andy's shirt
because I noticed Andy's shirt on this rewatch,
只是没打领带。安迪穿着一件衬衫，上面写着“Ben, Dover, you”（弯下腰，你），背面写着“apply within”（内有应聘），旁边还有一个箭头指向他的屁股。好的。所以很有趣的是，剧本里对安迪的衬衫是这么写的，因为我在这次重看时注意到了安迪的衬衫，
and I got curious about it.
Because what he's actually wearing is a blue t-shirt that says,
ask me about my butt, written in white letters.
But the word ask is spelled A-S-S-S-K.
The ass part is.
in red, it's in like big letters. So it's like capital A, S, and then little K. And it's such an
odd shirt. And I have to imagine it was made for this episode. What do you think Ed thought when
he like showed up to his like costume fitting? And they're like, you're wearing a shirt that just
我对它产生了好奇。因为他实际穿的是一件蓝色的T恤，上面用白字写着“问问我的屁股”（ask me about my butt）。但是“问”（ask）这个词拼成了 A-S-S-S-K。“ass”（屁股）这个部分是红色的，字体很大。所以它看起来就像是大写的 A、S，然后是小写的 K。这是一件很奇怪的衬衫。我不得不想象这是专门为这一集制作的。你觉得当埃德去试装的时候，他心里在想什么？他们对他说，你穿的一件衬衫上只
says like ass on it. Like I'd be like what the hell? And I just can't believe we didn't talk about it
in our original breakdown. I did take a screen grab of it and you can plainly see at 18 minutes and
six seconds, his shirt. I also want to point out that in that same scene, you can see that
Toby is wearing a sweatshirt that says Costa Rica. I loved that detail. I did too. And Oscar does
have on a windbreaker all day long, even though he's inside. And then I also found this gym
about Kelly's outfit in the candy bag alts. And Jenna, I think we should both read it. Okay. I want you
to read Kelly's lines and I'm going to read errands. Okay. Okay. And I'll do the stage direction.
Ready?
印着“ass”（屁股）这个词。要是我，我就会想，这到底是什么鬼？我真不敢相信我们当初在盘点时居然没聊到这个。我确实截了屏，在18分06秒时，你可以清楚地看到他的衬衫。我还想指出，在同一个场景中，你可以看到托比穿着一件印有“哥斯达黎加”（Costa Rica）字样的运动衫。我很喜欢这个细节。我也很喜欢。而且奥斯卡一整天都穿着防风夹克，尽管他在室内。然后我还从糖果袋备用场景中发现了关于凯莉服装的这个宝贝。珍娜，我觉得我们应该一起读一下。好的。我想让你读凯莉的台词，我来读艾琳的。好的。好的。我来读舞台指示。准备好了吗？
Yes.
Kelly costume interior annex.
Kelly wearing hip overalls and a fancy bra.
Erin is walking through.
Kelly says, do I look okay?
Toby said I'm dressed inappropriately.
Oh, no.
I think you look great.
准备好了。凯莉服装，内景附楼。凯莉穿着时髦的背带裤和一件精美的胸衣。艾琳走了过去。凯莉说，我看起来怎么样？托比说我穿衣服不得体。哦，不。我觉得你看起来棒极了。
Very cool.
Are those condom earrings?
Yeah, I designed them myself.
People really went all out.
I feel a little underdressed.
You could use a little work.
What kind of bra do you have going on under there?
Hmm. Condom earrings she made herself? Yeah. Oh, man. Lady, I have a question. Oh, okay. Are we too old to do the trend where you wear a suit, but you're not wearing a shirt? You just have a bra underneath. So you're wearing a blazer with just a bra. Right. Do you see any of the bra? Or is it just like the hint that it, does it, like, what's going on here? Do I see the bra?
太酷了。那是避孕套耳环吗？对，我自己设计的。大家真的是各出奇招。我觉得我穿得有点不够隆重。你确实需要好好打扮一下。你里面穿的是什么样胸衣？嗯。她自己做的避孕套耳环？对。天哪，我的天。女士，我有个问题。哦，好吧。我们是不是太老了，不能赶那种穿西装却不穿衬衫的潮流？里面只穿一件胸衣。所以你外面只穿一件西装外套，里面是一件胸衣。没错。你能看到胸衣吗？还是说只隐约露出来一点，它到底是怎样的？我能看到胸衣吗？
No, it's obvious I don't have a shirt on.
It's very obvious.
Okay.
Now, I do a thing all the time.
It's my favorite look where I wear a boostier underneath my suit.
It looks like a strapless boostier.
Right.
Under my suit.
不，很明显我没穿衬衫。非常明显。好吧。现在，我经常做一件事。这是我最喜欢的造型，我在西装里面穿一件紧身胸衣。看起来就像是一件无肩带的紧身胸衣。对。穿在西装里面。
But it's like it goes into my pants and everything.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about like a lace bra.
So what I've seen is skin to the pant.
But you're not seeing the bra.
It just looks like you have no clothes in a jewell.
jacket. Am I understanding? You see the bra. Oh. You see the lace bra peeking out underneath the jacket.
I mean, I, you know what? Why not? Why not? Just let me live, you know? Yeah. If you want to do it,
但它一直延伸到裤子里什么的。我说的不是那个。我说的是那种蕾丝胸衣。所以根据我看到的，从皮肤直接到裤子。但你看不到胸衣。看起来就像你在夹克里什么都没穿。我理解对了吗？你能看到胸衣。哦。你能看到蕾丝胸衣从夹克底下露出来。我的意思是，你知道吗？为什么不呢？为什么不呢？就让我随心所欲地生活吧，你知道的？对。如果你想这么穿，
do it. If that's your look, go for it. I don't know. I just think just own your style.
If that's your style. I think I would be just, I don't know. I think I'd be futzing.
with all of it all night because I'd be like, I'm not sure where the fabric's supposed to be.
But, you know, recently a friend of mine who's 60 did the black bra under a white kind of
crochet top.
And she was like, this is like a trend now and I like it.
And I was like, do it.
And yeah.
那就穿吧。如果这就是你的风格，那就去做吧。我不知道。我只是觉得，整晚我都会一直在那儿摆弄衣服，因为我会想，我不确定这块布料该待在哪个位置。不过，你知道，最近我有一个60岁的朋友，她在一种白色的钩针上衣里面穿了一件黑色的胸衣。然后她说，这现在是一种潮流，我挺喜欢的。我就对她说，那就穿吧。对啊。
And I thought she looked great.
So.
Yeah, I think now in my 50s, since I've moved into the zero F's portion of my.
my life. Yeah. I sort of feel like it. I think you should do it. Like not even about sexiness or whatever.
It's just like I didn't feel like finding a shirt. It was too much effort. That's funnier. That's funny to me.
Wait, let's just peel back the onion. Is that this isn't about fashion. This is just you don't feel like
finding a shirt. So you have a jacket you have a bra, call it a day. Well, I found this great suit,
and I love the pants, and I love the jacket. And I tried on probably, I don't know, eight shirts.
我觉得她看起来棒极了。所以。对，我觉得现在我50多岁了，既然我已经进入了人生中“完全不在乎”的阶段。对。我差不多就是这种感觉。我觉得你应该这么穿。甚至都不是为了性感什么的。就好像我只是懒得找一件衬衫。太费劲了。那样更有趣。这对我来说很有趣。等等，让我们深入剖析一下。这根本不是关于时尚。这只是因为你懒得找一件衬衫。所以你有一件夹克，你有一件胸衣，这就搞定了。好吧，我找到了这套棒极了的西装，我喜欢这条裤子，我也喜欢这件夹克。我大概试穿了，我不知道，八件衬衫。
None of them looked good. And at a certain point, I just put the jacket on. And I was like,
you know what? Maybe this is what it is. I'm done. Yeah. No shirt. Just fuck it.
I mean, all your bits and bobs are covered. Who cares? I mean, they're
more than covered. Yeah. Lady, I have a pair of shorts that are just old and they're my favorite
and they're getting a little ratty. They're like cutoffs, you know? And I put them on the other day
and they're short. And I thought, oh gosh, I'm 55. I probably shouldn't be wearing short gene
cutoffs, right? And I came downstairs in them and Josh like immediately was like, hey.
And so I was like, well, you know what, I guess I still can rock them.
没有一件好看的。然后在某个时刻，我直接把夹克穿上了。然后我就想，你知道吗？也许这就是它该有的样子。我搞定啦。对。没有衬衫。管他呢。我的意思是，你所有的重要部位都被遮住了。谁在乎呢？我的意思是，它们可不止是被遮住了。对。女士，我有一条短裤，它们已经很旧了，是我的最爱，而且有点破旧了。它们有点像剪边短裤，你知道吗？前几天我把它们穿上了，它们很短。然后我想，哦天哪，我55岁了。我可能不应该穿牛仔剪边短裤了吧，对吧？我穿着它们下楼了，乔什立刻就说，嘿。所以我当时就想，好吧，你知道吗，我想我还是能驾驭它们的。
I say wear them.
Yeah.
You know who would wear them?
How's this transition?
What?
Meredith.
Meredith is the queen of zero Fs.
Well, wait a second.
我说穿吧。对。你知道谁会穿吗？这个过渡怎么样？什么？梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思是“完全不在乎”女王。好吧，等一下。
Wait a second.
Now I don't know.
I don't know if I want to be like using Meredith as my style inspiration.
Incidentally, I was curious how the shooting draft described.
Maritith's casual Friday look.
And here's what it said.
You know, after Toby reprimands her, it says Meredith becomes defensive and stands up.
She's wearing a tube dress that's riding a little too high.
等一下。现在我不知道了。我不知道我是否还想把梅雷迪思作为我的风格灵感来源。顺便说一句，我很好奇拍摄剧本是如何描述梅雷迪思的“随意星期五”造型的。它是这么写的。你知道的，在托比训斥她之后，上面写着梅雷迪思变得很不服气，站了起来。她穿着一件稍微有点往上跑的无肩带连衣裙。
But you know what happened?
Yeah.
She was a woman in her 50s.
She was standing in her closet.
And she was like, I'm tired.
I'm not going to put anything else with this.
This is it.
Yeah.
但你知道发生了什么吗？对。她是一个50多岁的女人。她站在自己的衣橱里。然后她想，我累了。我不想再往这上面搭配任何别的东西了。就是这样。对。
That's all Meredith had for that day.
She was done.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Well, I was curious if, quote, casual Friday was still a thing in offices, right?
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. So I went online. I did my Googling. And lady, first of all, can you guess which department? Matt, feel free to weigh in on this as well. Guess which department in corporate offices has been labeled as the most casually dressed by folks online?
IT? Yes. Yes. IT, you got it right away. Matt, you didn't even get a chance.
to chime in. I didn't get a chance. It was too high. I had to familiarize myself with the various
different departments. You were going through your head, like human resources, accounting. Yeah,
梅雷迪思那天就只有这些了。她受够了。对。对。好吧，我很好奇，所谓的“随意星期五”在办公室里是不是还流行，对吧？嗯嗯。嗯嗯。所以我上网了。我谷歌了一下。女士，首先，你能猜到哪个部门？马特，你也可以畅所欲言。猜猜网民们认为公司办公室里哪个部门的着装最随便？IT部门？对。没错。IT部门，你一下子就猜对了。马特，你甚至都没机会
IT is notoriously the most casual of any corporate office. And then I found a Reddit thread that had
some fun shares about this whole casual Friday office tradition. So basically, you guys,
it really has become a thing of the past, not to be a womp womp. But a lot of people in the 2000s,
said they would have to dress up Monday through Thursday, you know, suit and tie. But on Friday,
they were allowed to wear khakis with no tie. That was sort of like the standard, like,
corporate office thing. Yeah. What's interesting about that is that casual Friday was not even,
like, fully casual. It didn't even mean jeans. It just meant, like, less corporate, but you were still
sort of business casual, I think. Yeah. Casual Friday was basically Dwight in this episode.
插话了。我都没机会插话。语速太快了。我不得不先熟悉一下各个不同的部门。你脑子里在想，比如人力资源部、会计部。对，
Yes, exactly. Yeah. And then another.
person wrote in and said, my offices actually got every other Friday off, and we used to call
our working Friday Aloha Friday, and many people wore Hawaiian shirts. That was early 2000s, and over
time, many of the Hawaiian shirt wearers retired. I recently brought back a few Aloha shirts and
started wearing them on Fridays, and one of the old timers said, damn, I forgot all about
Aloha Friday. A much younger co-worker asked what that was. So we explained that in the old days,
many people would wear Hawaiian slash Aloha shirts on Fridays. She asked if we could do that again,
and we both said, of course, just wear an Aloha shirt. And lady, this made me think of our crew.
IT部门出了名是任何公司办公室里最随性的。然后我在Reddit上看到一个帖子，里面有一些关于这个“随意星期五”办公室传统的有趣分享。所以基本上，伙计们，这真的已经成为过去了，虽然听起来有点扫兴。但2000年代的很多人说，他们周一到周四必须盛装打扮，你知道的，西装革履。但到了周 Friday，他们被允许穿卡其裤，不系领带。那差不多就是标准的、类似公司办公室的那种风格。对。关于这一点有趣的是，“随意星期五”甚至都不是完全随意的。它甚至不意味着穿牛仔裤。它只是意味着，比如，不那么像公司正装，但你觉得你仍然属于商务休闲范畴。对。“随意星期五”基本上就是这一集里德怀特的穿搭。
Remember our crew on Fridays would often wear a Hawaiian shirt? They would. Yeah. But now we're the
old timers. We are. That's like an old-fashioned tradition. I know.
And then this fellow from Germany wrote in with this curveball, he said in the thread,
does your office have a non-casual Fridays?
This really got people chatting, okay?
He said he works in IT, and since his department usually just wears jeans and t-shirts,
a group of them thought it would be fun to introduce a non-casual Friday as a bit of a joke,
where people actually dress up and often kind of formally.
是的，完全正确。对。然后另一个人写信说，我的办公室实际上每隔一个周五放假，我们过去常常把我们工作的那个周五叫做“阿罗哈星期五”（Aloha Friday），许多人会穿夏威夷衫。那是2000年代初，随着时间的推移，许多穿夏威夷衫的人退休了。我最近又拿出了几件夏威夷衫，开始在周五穿，其中一个老员工说，天哪，我都把阿罗哈星期五这事忘光了。一个年轻得多的同事问那是什么。于是我们解释说，在过去，许多人会在周五穿夏威夷/阿罗哈衬衫。她问我们能不能再这样做，我们两个都说，当然可以，穿一件夏威夷衫就行了。女士，这让我想起了我们的剧组。
And folks love this.
Lady, people shared that they do fancy Fridays or, quote,
formal Fridays or they'll have like tie Thursdays. Isn't that so funny? Yeah. It's so crazy because the pandemic
really changed office fashion when everybody was working from home and then it was time to go back into
a shared workspace. I think people were like, I'll come back to the office, but I'm not wearing that
shit anymore. Like I want my comfy clothes all the time. I've noticed. Yeah. So now it's like flipped.
It's like you're casual all week, and then if you want for fun, some people dress up on Fridays.
Yeah.
还记得我们的剧组在周五经常穿夏威夷衫吗？他们会的。对。但现在我们成了老员工了。我们确实是。这就好像是一个老派传统。我知道。然后这个来自德国的家伙提出了一个意想不到的问题，他在帖子中说，你们办公室有“非随意星期五”吗？这真的让大家聊嗨了，好吧？他说他在IT部门工作，由于他们的部门通常只穿牛仔裤和T恤，他们中的一群人觉得作为一个玩笑，引入一个“非随意星期五”会很有趣，大家在这一天真的会盛装打扮，而且通常穿得比较正式。
I wonder how long that's going to last.
I feel like as newer generations who didn't experience the pandemic start going into the workplace,
I wonder if it will become the way it was, if it will become like you'll have like this like fancier business attire again.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Okay.
And then two more things that I thought were interesting is one person,
they worked at an engineering firm in Texas, and they did a completely optional, but it was really
大家都很喜欢这个。女士，人们分享说他们会搞“精美星期五”或者所谓的“正式星期五”，或者他们会有像“领带星期四”这样的活动。是不是很有趣？对。这太疯狂了，因为大流行确实改变了办公室的时尚，当时每个人都在家办公，然后是时候回到共享的工作空间了。我觉得人们当时的想法是，我会回办公室，但我再也不穿那破衣服了。就像我一直想要舒服的衣服。我注意到了。对。所以现在情况反过来了。就像你一整周都很休闲，然后如果你想的话，为了好玩，有些人会在周五盛装打扮。对。
fun, Western Wednesday, and you could wear cowboy shirts, boots, cowboy hats. And I thought that was
kind of fun. Like, I wonder if they're a regional dress-up days at different offices, you know?
And lastly, a bunch of folks shared that Friday is a work-from-home day. And most of their
colleagues aren't even in the office. And I thought, oh, man, Michael would have hated that.
That's the most casual version of a Friday.
It is.
So there you go.
Those are some casual Friday trends happening now.
我不知道这能持续多久。我觉得随着没有经历过大流行的年轻一代开始进入职场，我不知道它会不会恢复到以前的样子，它会不会再次变得像以前那样拥有更华丽的商务着装。对。我不知道。好吧。还有两件我觉得很有趣的事情，一个是某人在德克萨斯州的一家工程公司工作，他们举办了一个完全自愿但真的很有趣的“西部星期三”，你可以穿牛仔衬衫、靴子、牛仔帽。我觉得这挺有意思的。我就想，不知道不同办公室里有没有地方特色的着装日，你知道吗？最后，许多人分享说周五是居家办公日。他们的大多数同事甚至都不在办公室。我想，哦天哪，迈克尔一定会讨厌那样的。那是周五最随意的版本了。确实是。好了，这就是现在正在流行的一些“随意星期五”潮流。
Thank you, Angela.
Well, I want to share a new scene that was added back to the super fan version.
It happens at the Jim Pam Dwight Desclump.
And Jim has a gift for Pam.
He's welcoming her back.
And she opens it and it looks homemade.
It's this little island.
and there are little dolls.
谢谢你，安吉拉。嗯，我想分享一个被加回到超级粉丝版里的新场景。它发生在吉姆、帕姆和德怀特的办公桌集群那里。吉姆给帕姆准备了一个礼物。他在欢迎她回来。她打开了它，看起来是自制的小岛。
There's a doll representing her,
one representing Jim, one representing Dwight.
Why don't we listen?
All right, you're ready to wait?
Ready for what?
What's this?
It's a little gift.
On behalf of desk area clump number one,
这是一个小岛，上面有一些小玩偶。有一个代表她的玩偶，一个代表吉姆的，一个代表德怀特的。我们为什么不听听看呢？好了，准备好了吗？准备好什么？这是什么？是一个小礼物。代表办公桌集群一号，
we welcome you to our little island.
Love, Jim, and Dwight.
Okay, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I had nothing to do with that, okay?
I missed the storage containers
that used to occupy that spot.
Thank you, Dwight.
And you obscure my view of the shredder.
我们欢迎你来到我们的小岛。爱你的，吉姆和德怀特。等等，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。这跟我一点关系都没有，好吗？我怀念以前占据那个位置的储物柜了。谢谢你，德怀特。而且你挡住了我对碎纸机的视线。
Okay, let's get back to the ceremony. Here we go.
Oh, I love it. That is so cute.
It's us and Dwight.
I'm supposed to be fishing?
Barbaric.
You're a train conductor?
Yeah, it's my job on the island.
And I'm a giant Amazon woman.
好了，让我们回到仪式上来。我们开始吧。哦，我太喜欢了。这太可爱了。是我们和德怀特。我是在钓鱼吗？太野蛮了。你是个火车列车员？对，这是我在岛上的工作。我是个巨大的亚马逊女战士。
We need an attraction to raise money to get the train to the island.
That island is completely implausible.
I love it.
So there you have it.
I guess Jim made her...
When did he make?
it? How did he make it without her seeing it? Where does Jim do any of it? Like, where do his pranks
happen? All of it. I do love, though, that Dwight finds the size of the island disproportionate.
我们需要一个景点来筹集资金把火车运到岛上。那个岛完全不合乎情理。我太喜欢了。所以，这就是全部了。我猜吉姆给她做了一个……他是什么时候做的？他怎么在不让她看到的情况下做出来的？吉姆是在哪里做这些的呢？所有的恶作剧都是在哪发生的？全都在。不过我确实很喜欢德怀特觉得这个岛的尺寸不成比例。
Like, this is a guy that loves bobbleheads. You know what I mean? Yeah. Well, don't you wish you
still had that prop? Oh, I would love to have that on my desk right now. I know. Well, thanks to Michael
B, again, from Lebanon, Pennsylvania. We have this little piece of information about that gift from Jim.
Michael says, according to the Dunder Mifflin accounting actuals that he has from the
Phil Shea prop papers, that island and figurines cost $2,840 and 50 cents and was made by movie art.
What? Did you see it?
Wait, are you saying you don't think the little island looks like it costs $2,800?
I mean, in no way does it look like it cost $2,800. I feel like it costs $2,800. I feel like
就像这是一个喜欢摇头娃娃的家伙。你知道我的意思吗？对。嗯，难道你不希望你还留着那个道具吗？哦，我现在真想把它放在我的桌子上。我知道。好吧，多亏了来自宾夕法尼亚州黎明市的迈克尔·B（Michael B.），我们又有了关于吉姆送的那份礼物的这条信息。迈克尔说，根据他从菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）道具文件中获得的邓德·米夫林会计实际花销，那个岛和雕像花费了2840美元50美分，是由电影艺术公司制作的。什么？你看到了吗？等等，你是说你觉得那个小岛看起来不像是值2800美元吗？我的意思是，它无论如何都不像是值2800美元的样子。我觉得它价值2800美元。我觉得
I could make that in an afternoon with stuff I found in my house.
I mean, that's the point of it.
It's supposed to look like that.
Right.
It is.
But yeah, that was an expensive prop.
And then it got cut out.
我用家里找到的东西一个下午就能做出来。我的意思是，这正是它的意义所在。它就应该看起来是这样的。对。确实如此。确实如此。不过，那确实是个昂贵的道具。然后它被剪掉了。
I know.
Dang it.
I wonder who has it.
I don't know.
Well, next up is the scene in the kitchen where Pam and Phyllis are going to discover that they are wearing the same outfit.
Before we dive into that scene, I needed to address something.
Okay.
So in our original breakdown of this episode, I did a mini deep dive on the local department store that Pam says she went to in the Steamedown Mall to get her outfit.
我知道。该死。不知道谁把它留着了。我不知道。好吧，接下来是厨房里的场景，帕姆和菲利斯发觉她们穿了同一套衣服。在我们深入探讨那个场景之前，我需要解决一件事。好吧。所以在我们对这一集的最初盘点中，我深入探讨了帕姆在斯蒂姆当购物中心（Steamedown Mall）说她去买衣服的本地百货公司。
I pronounced it Bosscoves.
And guess what lady?
That is not how you say it.
Oh.
We got a little fan mail flurry about it.
And by the way, everyone that wrote in, you guys were really kind with me.
So thank you.
But I did feel the need to say it properly for you all.
我以前把它的名字念成Bosscoves。你猜怎么着，女士？那根本不是那种念法。哦。我们为此收到了一小波粉丝来信。顺便说一句，所有写信来的朋友，你们对我都很好。所以谢谢你们。但我确实觉得有必要为大家好好纠正一下发音。
So I'm just going to let the CEO of the company do it so I don't mess it up.
Here's a little snippet of him talking about his store.
So what the heck is a Boscoves anyway?
Well, we're the largest family-owned department store with 50 stores in this part of the country.
In Monroe County, you're going to be number 51.
I can't wait to meet you.
Come on in.
Let me show you what a Boscoves is all about.
所以我打算直接让公司的CEO来念，免得我把它搞砸。这里有一小段他谈论自己店铺的视频。那么，Boscoves到底是个什么鬼？嗯，我们是最大的家族式百货公司，在这个国家的這個地区拥有50家门店。在门罗县，你们将成为第51家。我迫不及待地想见到你们。请进。让我向你们展示Boscoves的一切。
Oh.
Boscoves.
That was Jim Boscov.
Jim, I'm really sorry.
I got your store name wrong.
And the store looks awesome.
I mean, that video, I was like, wow, the store has everything.
Well, lady, you know what I found out?
哦。Boscoves。那是吉姆·博斯科夫（Jim Boscov）。吉姆，我真的很抱歉。我把你们店的名字念错了。而且这家店看起来太棒了。我是说，看了那段视频，我就觉得，哇，这家店应有尽有。好吧，女士，你知道我发现了什么吗？
It almost wasn't Boscoves.
In the table draft of this episode, Pam says they got their outfits at, quote, Express for Women at the Steamedown Mall.
Oh, well, I'm glad they went with the local store, aren't you?
Yeah, that was a good rewrite.
All right.
So now Phyllis has her famous line, close your mouth, sweetie, you look like a trout.
Mm-hmm.
I remember Phyllis told us that that is one of the lines people were.
差一点它就不叫Boscoves了。在这个剧集的初稿剧本中，帕姆说她们的衣服是在，引用一下，“蒸汽镇购物中心的女性快车（Express for Women）”买的。哦，好吧，我很高兴他们最后选用了本地的那家店，你呢？对，那是一个很好的重写。好的。现在菲利斯有了她那句著名的台词：“闭嘴，甜心，你看起来像条虹膜大鳟鱼。”嗯哼。我记得菲利斯告诉过我们，那是人们在剧中。
quote to her most often from the show. Yes, and I've said that it was very hard not to laugh in this
moment because just any time that sweet, sweet Phyllis has to say something like really biting,
it is so funny. I also wanted to point out that in the superfan episode, there is a new top
and bottom to the scene that has an extra little joke. At the top of the scene, Pam is alone in the
kitchen. She's making her tea, and Creed walks in the door just as the microwave is beeping. And he
opens it, he takes out a burrito, and then he walks into the annex.
And then there's the scene with Pam and Phyllis, noticing that they have the same outfit on.
After the scene is over, and Phyllis has said her famous line, Aaron walks into the kitchen,
最经常对她进行引用的台词之一。是的，而且我说过，在这个时刻要忍住不笑真的很难，因为每当那个甜美、善良的菲利斯不得不说一些非常刻薄的话时，都太搞笑了。我还想指出的是，在超级粉丝版剧集中，这个场景的开头和结尾都有所增加，多了一个额外的小笑话。在场景的开头，帕姆独自在厨房。她正在泡茶，微波炉发出哔哔声的瞬间，克里德走进了门。他打开微波炉，拿出一个卷饼，然后走进了附楼。接着就是帕姆和菲利斯发现她们穿了同一套衣服的场景。场景结束后，菲利斯说出了她那句著名的台词，亚伦走进了厨房，
checks the microwave, and she's really confused, and she turns to Pam, and she says,
Did you see me put a burrito in there?
Because her burrito is missing.
And I just think it's such a great example of the kind of things that we had to lose
in order to make the broadcast version of these episodes fit for time.
These superfan episodes, like, you're able to fill out the world with, like, mundane office life like this, like getting your burrito stolen out of the microwave.
And for the most part, the extra stuff in the super fan of Casual Friday are just those little scene extensions.
And they're really fun.
检查着微波炉，她感到非常困惑，转过身对帕姆说：“你看到我把卷饼放进去了吗？”因为她的卷饼不见了。我只是觉得这真是一个很好的例子，展示了为了让这些剧集的广播版符合时长，我们不得不删减掉的那类内容。这些超级粉丝版剧集，就像是你能用诸如办公室平凡生活之类的内容来充实整个世界，比如你在微波炉里的卷饼被偷了。而且在大多数情况下，《休闲星期五》超级粉丝版里多出来的内容，都只是那些小小的场景延伸。它们真的很有趣。
I just love it.
I love that burrito moment, made it back in.
And Dave Rogers, thank you.
Well, listen, next up, Dwight is going to gather everyone down in the warehouse to make his case.
Remember, he's written a memo to the sales staff in Invisible Inc. That is actually urine.
And they are mad because Michael has come back and he has made Pam and Ryan salespeople.
And they're not giving back the clients that they stole when they left to make Michael Scott paper company.
So everyone's really mad.
我太喜欢了。我喜欢那个卷饼的桥段，它被加回来了。还有戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers），谢谢你。好吧，听着，接下来，德怀特要把大家召集到仓库里为自己辩护。记住，他给销售人员写了一封隐形墨水备忘录。那其实是尿液。他们很生气，因为迈克尔回来了，并让帕姆和瑞安成为了销售人员。他们没有把当初离开去创建迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司时偷走的客户还回来。所以每个人都很生气。
So Dwight calls this meeting.
and he is down there with Phyllis Stanley and Andy,
and this is extended in the superfan version.
Dwight is explaining that failure is not an option.
Have a listen.
If we do nothing, we fail and failure is not an option.
Well, to be clear, it is an option.
Not in my book.
于是德怀特召开了这个会议。他和菲利斯、斯坦利以及安迪在下面，这在超级粉丝版中得到了扩展。德怀特在解释说失败不是一种选择。听听看。如果我们什么都不做，我们就会失败，而失败不是一种选项。好吧，说清楚点，这确实是一个选项。在我看来不是。
My book, the cover is failure is not an option.
It is an option.
Not in my book.
Literally.
What book?
What are you?
Did you write it?
Yeah.
在我看来，封面就是失败不是一种选项。这是一个选项。在我看来不是。字面意思。什么书？你是什么人？你自己写的？对。
failure is not an option.
Very serious.
I got curious about the phrase, failure is not an option.
I was like, where did that come from?
What did you find?
I was completely surprised by the answer.
Where do you guys think it came from?
Matt, Angela, if you had to guess the phrase,
失败不是一种选项。非常严肃。我对“失败不是一种选项”这个短语产生了好奇。我想，这到底是从哪里来的？你发现了什么？我对这个答案感到非常惊讶。你们觉得它是从哪里来的？马特，安吉拉，如果让你们猜这个短语，
failure is not an option, unless you know, maybe you know.
It sounds like a military term.
Yeah, that's what I was going to say.
I was like, oh, this is Winston Churchill.
No, it came from that.
the movie Apollo 13.
Not the actual mission by the astronauts.
Correct.
失败不是一种选项，除非你知道，也许你知道。听起来像是个军事术语。对，我刚才也这么想。我想，哦，这是温斯顿·丘吉尔说的。不，它来自于那部。电影《阿波罗13号》。不是宇航员的实际任务。没错。
So sort of.
I mean, influenced by.
So according to Wikipedia, in preparation for the movie, the script writers, Al
Reinhert and Bill Broils, they interviewed flight controller Jerry Bostic.
They wanted to get some intel on like what is mission control really like?
And one of the questions they asked him was, weren't there times?
when everybody or even just a few people were completely panicked. And Jerry said, no, when bad things
happened, we just calmly laid out all the options and failure was not one of them. That was what he said
所以算是吧。也就是受其影响。根据维基百科的说法，在筹备这部电影时，编剧阿尔·赖因哈特（Al Reinhert）和比尔·布罗伊尔斯（Bill Broils）采访了飞行控制员杰瑞·博斯蒂克（Jerry Bostic）。他们想了解一些内幕，比如任务控制中心到底是什么样的？他们问他的其中一个问题是，难道没有过那种。所有人甚至哪怕只是少数人完全陷入恐慌的时刻吗？杰瑞说，没有，当糟糕的事情发生时，我们只是冷静地列出所有的选项，而失败绝对不是其中之一。这就是他当时对他们说的话。
to them. And then this guy, Jerry, said months later, he learned that when the writers got in their
car to leave, the writers said, that's it. That's the tagline for this whole movie. Failure is
not an option. And then they gave that line to Ed Harris, who played mission control officer Gene
Krantz. And then later, Gene Krantz wrote a memoir titled, Failure is Not an Option.
This is Life, imitating art, art imitating life. Before 1995, were people not really saying failure
is not an option? I mean, I really deep dived it. I don't recall saying it before then, but
isn't that crazy? That's what surprised me, because I felt like that's as a lot. I was,
old as it is. That's as far back in history as that phrase goes. But what was also crazy is that
然后这个名叫杰瑞的家伙说，几个月后，他得知当编剧们上车离开时，编剧们说：“就是这个。这就是整部电影的点睛之句。失败不是一种选项。”然后他们把这句台词交给了饰演任务控制官吉恩·克兰兹（Gene Krantz）的埃德·哈里斯（Ed Harris）。后来，吉恩·克兰兹写了一本回忆录，书名就叫《失败不是一种选项》。这就是生活模仿艺术，艺术模仿生活。在1995年之前，人们难道真的不说“失败不是一种选项”吗？我是说，我真的深入研究过。我不记得在那之前有人说过，但这不是太疯狂了吗？这就是让我感到惊讶的地方，因为我觉得这很常见。我是说，它有多古老。那就是这个短语在历史上能追溯到的最远时间了。但同样疯狂的是，
Gene Krantz never said it. He never actually said that phrase. But his character in the movie said
it. But that was like the overall vibe of mission control. I mean, it's good. It's concise. You get it.
Failure's not an option, period. Yeah. It's very direct. What a star-studded cast, by the way.
Oh, if you haven't watched Apollo 13 in a while, I'd like to say that the movie holds up.
I watched it recently.
Yeah, it's been a while.
It's great.
All right.
吉恩·克兰兹从来没有说过这句话。他实际上从未说过那个短语。但他在电影里的角色说了。但这可以说是任务控制中心整体的氛围。我是说，这很好。很精炼。你懂的。失败不是一种选项，句号。对。非常直接。顺便说一句，这是多么全明星的阵容啊。哦，如果你有一段时间没看《阿波罗13号》了，我想说这部电影经久不衰。我最近刚看过。对，已经过去一段时间了。太棒了。好了。
Well, listen, back to this scene.
I do want to bring up one other thing.
Jim is going to tell Pam, Michael, and Ryan that, quote, there may or may not be, but definitely is a mutiny forming in the warehouse right now.
And I have some candy bag alts for you, lady.
Okay.
Michael is ticked off, and he has this talking head.
I want to play what made it in the episode, and then I'm going to read some alts.
Okay, great.
好吧，听着，回到这个场景。我确实想提出另一件事。吉姆要告诉帕姆、迈克尔和瑞安，引用一下，“仓库里现在可能正在酝酿，也可能没有，但绝对正在酝酿一场兵变。”我这里有一些备选的糖果袋笑话给你，女士。好的。迈克尔气坏了，他有这样一个单人独白镜头。我想播放正片里播出的部分，然后再读一些备选项。好的，太棒了。
The old Michael Scott might have taken this, but not the new Michael Scott.
They are in for a bitter surprise.
I am not to be truffled with.
He's not to be truffled with.
He's not.
No, don't truffle with him.
Don't truffle with him.
Don't even go near his trials and tribunis.
老迈克尔·斯科特可能会忍气吞声，但新迈克尔·斯科特不会。他们要大吃苦头了。我可不是好惹的。他可不是好惹的。他真的不是。不，别去惹他。别去惹他。甚至不要去碰他的麻烦和苦难。
That's right.
But here were some candy bag alts for that particular talking head.
Michael would have said, in my house, in my house, in my house, in my house?
You just would have said that over and over. Here's another one. When you owe me an apology and instead
give me a mutiny, you are asking for a smackdown. What's that? Smackdown truck backing up.
We've got a shipment of Smackdown. Where would you like it? Right here, you need to sign for it.
Gladly. Oh, those are some of my friends.
favorite Michael talking heads, and they're my favorite ones that Steve does, because he nails
没错。但对于那个特定的单人独白镜头，有一些备选的糖果袋笑话。迈克尔会说，在我的地盘上，在我的地盘上，在我的地盘上，在我的地盘上？你就会一遍又一遍地这么说。这里还有另一个。当你欠我一个道歉，给我的却是一场兵变，你是在自讨苦吃。那是什么？重拳卡车在倒车。我们有一批重拳到货了。你想放在哪？就在这，你需要签收一下。乐意之至。哦，这些是我最喜欢的迈克尔的单人独白，也是我最喜欢史蒂夫演绎的部分，因为他把
that timing so great. Also, this is bringing up an aspect of this episode that I really, really
liked, which is the whole thing for Michael in this episode is he's waiting all day for people
to apologize to him. Like, his come from is that he is owed an apology, and I love it so much.
It's one of my favorite, like, mini storylines within this episode.
I really wish we could have heard Steve say we've got a shipment of Smackdown.
I know.
All right.
Here's another one.
那个时机掌握得太棒了。另外，这也勾起了我这一集中非常非常喜欢的一个方面，那就是迈克尔在这一集里的整条线索都是他一整天都在等待别人向他道歉。就像他的出发点是别人欠他一个道歉，我太喜欢这个设定了。这是这一集中我最喜欢的迷你剧情线之一。我真的很希望听到史蒂夫说“我们有一批重拳到货了”。我知道。好吧。这里还有另一个。
Michael would have said,
Mutiny?
Not on my ship.
Not while I'm captain.
The only way they could get away with mutiny is if they took over or something.
And that's not going to happen.
So good.
I love it.
迈克尔会说：“兵变？绝不在我的船上。只要我是船长，就绝无可能。他们能逃脱兵变惩罚的唯一可能，就是他们夺权或者别的什么。而这绝不会发生。”太棒了。我太喜欢了。
Well, Michael eventually brings Dwight, Andy, Phyllis, and Stanley down to the warehouse,
and he's going to apologize.
He is going to say that he has realized that he was the process.
problem. He has this talking head where he says that he has looked at the situation 100 different
ways and in every one of them he is in the wrong. It's so funny. There was a different talking head
in the table draft. He is still going to realize that he needs to apologize, but instead,
it would have gone like this. He was going to say, when I was four, a girl in my nursery
school was crying and crying, and I was irritated because she had the best block, the block with
好吧，迈克尔最终把德怀特、安迪、菲利斯和斯坦利带到了仓库，他要道歉。他要说他已经意识到他才是问题所在。他有一个单人独白镜头，在其中他说他已经从100个不同的角度审视了这种情况，在每一种情况下他都是错的。太搞笑了。初稿剧本里有一个不同的单人独白。他仍然会意识到他需要道歉，但原本的剧情会是这样的。他会说，当我四岁的时候，我幼儿园里的一个小女孩一直在哭个不停，我很烦，因为她有最好的积木，那块带有
wheels. So that's all I could focus on. And then later, when we were eating cookies, I realized
she was crying because I bit her. Today, I realized that I bit Stanley and I bit Phyllis and I bit
Andy and I spit on Dwight. It's so ridiculous. So ridiculous. But listen, finally,
in our revisiting of Casual Friday,
there's another storyline in this episode,
and it is that Michael has to decide
between Ryan and Pam for a single sales job.
He's going to have to make one of them a salesperson,
轮子的积木。所以我所有的注意力都集中在那上面。后来，当我们吃饼干时，我意识到她哭是因为我咬了她。今天，我意识到我咬了斯坦利，我咬了菲利斯，我咬了安迪，我还吐口水在德怀特身上。太荒谬了。太荒谬了。但是听着，最后，在我们重温《休闲星期五》时，这一集中还有另一条剧情线，那就是迈克尔必须在瑞安和帕姆之间做出选择，以决定一个销售岗位。他必须让他们其中一个人成为销售人员，
and then one of them, I don't know what they're going to be, right?
And the episode ends with one of Michael's famous fake firing scenes.
I love these scenes.
And he ultimately gives the sales job to Pam.
Well, there was an alternate ending to this episode.
episode that was in the table draft. And it hints at something. This got cut out, but they clearly
liked this idea and they saved it because in the table draft, he gives the sales job to Ryan.
Ooh. So in the actual episode, he gives it to Pam, right? But in the alternate ending, he gave
然后另一个人，我不知道他们会是什么职位，对吧？剧集以迈克尔标志性的虚假解雇场景之一结束。我太喜欢这些场景了。他最终把销售岗位给了帕姆。嗯，这一集其实有一个备用结局，它存在于剧本初稿中。它暗示了一些事情。这部分被剪掉了，但他们显然很喜欢这个想法并把它保留了下来，因为在剧本初稿中，他把销售岗位给了瑞安。哦。所以在正片里，他把它给了帕姆，对吧？但在备用结局中，他把
the sales job to Ryan, and he makes Pam the office manager. Oh. Which, by the way, when you get into
like what this job is. It's basically office administrator, which is the job that Pam is later going to
make up for herself when she leaves sales. But he makes her, quote unquote, office manager and tells her
that her first responsibility is to enforce the dress code. So basically, her job is going to be every
job Michael doesn't want to do. Oh my gosh. That's perfect. And she has to start with Meredith.
And there's this whole scene that was a tag at the end of the episode of Pam trying to explain to Meredith why her outfit is inappropriate.
And is Meredith just like go F yourself?
Pretty much.
销售岗位给了瑞安，并让帕姆担任办公室经理。哦。顺便说一句，当你去了解这个工作到底是什么时。这基本上就是办公室行政人员，也就是帕姆后来离开销售岗位后为自己虚构的职位。但他让她担任所谓的办公室经理，并告诉她她的首要职责是执行着装规范。所以基本上，她的工作就是迈克尔所有不想做的工作。哦天哪。太完美了。而且她必须从梅雷迪思开始。剧集结尾的彩蛋里有整整一个场景，是帕姆试图向梅雷迪思解释为什么她的穿着不合时宜。而梅雷迪思的反应是不是就像滚蛋一样？差不多吧。
Yeah.
That's kind of evil genius of Michael, though, is to make Pam always the fall guy, like always taking the heat.
Mm-hmm.
I just loved this.
Lady, I loved revisiting this episode.
I loved re-watching it.
I've been re-watching episodes now more and more.
and they make me happy.
对。不过这可以说是迈克尔的邪恶天才之处，就是总是让帕姆当替罪羊，总是让她承受压力。嗯哼。我太喜欢这个了。女士，我太喜欢重温这一集了。我喜欢重看它。我现在越来越频繁地重看这些剧集了，它们让我感到快乐。
Mm-hmm.
Me too.
So thank you so much for writing in
with your suggestions and questions
about specific episodes
and superfan versions.
They're making us dig back in
and it's really fun.
嗯哼。我也是。非常感谢你们写信提出对特定剧集和超级粉丝版的建议和问题。这促使我们深入挖掘，真的非常有趣。
Well, listen, why don't we take a break?
And then we'll be back
with our Around the Town
and our office question of the week.
Well, we are back, and it's time for
Around the Town.
I'm going to start us off
with some snail mill from Danny G.
好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？然后我们会回来带来“走访小镇”和“本周办公室问题”。好了，我们回来了，是时候进入“走访小镇”了。我先从丹尼·G（Danny G）寄来的一封实体信开始。
We got a lovely car
from Danny, and she shared that the front of it was painted by her grandma. Look at that, Jenna. Isn't that gorgeous?
Oh, it's a turkey. Yeah. It's really detailed. It's a very detailed, beautiful painting of a turkey. I'm
to put that in our stories, Danny. And Danny went on to say many wonderful things about her love of the podcast,
but I had to share this fun, The Office crossover. Danny said, my aunt is a prolific stunt woman,
a regular double on Charmed, tons of hit movies, etc.
So you can imagine my utter shock when I was nonchalantly listening to episode 189,
Free Family Portrait and heard you throw out her name, Nancy Thurston.
我们收到了丹尼寄来的一张可爱的卡片，她分享说卡片的前面是她奶奶画的。看看那个，詹娜。是不是太棒了？哦，是一只火鸡。对。非常详细。这是一幅非常详细、美丽的火鸡画作。我要把它发到我们的快拍里，丹尼。丹尼接着表达了许多关于她对播客的热爱的美妙言辞，但我不得不分享这个有趣的《办公室》跨界彩蛋。丹尼说，我的姨妈是一位高产的特技女演员，《圣女魔咒》的常规替身，参演过数不清的热门电影，等等。所以你可以想象当我漫不经心地听着第189集《免费全家福》并听到你随口说出她的名字南希·瑟斯顿（Nancy Thurston）时，我是多么的震惊。
She is very humble about her work, so I didn't know, and I called her immediately.
Wow.
Isn't that so great?
Yes.
So Danny's aunt was on our show as a stunt woman,
and I just thought that was so fun that she learned that.
tidbit from listening to office ladies. Danny went on to say that if we want to go to a train
museum, we shouldn't miss the one in San Diego that does the Polar Express in the winter. She also
她对自己的工作非常谦逊，所以我并不知道，我立刻就给她打了电话。哇。是不是太棒了？是的。所以丹尼的姨妈曾作为特技女演员出现在我们的节目中，我觉得她从收听《办公室女士》中了解到这个趣闻真是太有趣了。丹尼接着说，如果我们想去参观火车博物馆，我们千万不要错过圣迭戈的那家，它们在冬天会举办“极地特快”活动。她还
added PS, I've started saying chunk it and PPS. Toby is totally the Scranton Strangler.
Thank you, Danny. Amazing. Well, we also got a letter from Samantha S in St. Charles, Missouri.
Hello, St. Charles, Missouri. I've been there many times. Samantha said,
Evelyn Clark, known as the I-70 fence lady, has delighted highway drivers for years with the messages
she would put on her fence using colorful cups. From happy birthdays to congrats, grads, and happy holidays,
Evelyn has shouted out to so many people over the years. And although Evelyn has now moved
from that home, every St. Charles resident knows exactly which patch of fence would be wishing them
well on their travels. Aw. I freaking love people who bring joy to their communities like this.
补充说，附言：我开始说“块状物（chunk it）”了，还有附言二：托比绝对是斯克兰顿扼杀者。谢谢你，丹尼。太棒了。好吧，我们还收到了来自密苏里州圣查尔斯的萨曼莎·S（Samantha S）的一封信。你好，密苏里州圣查尔斯。我去过那里很多次。萨曼莎说，伊芙琳·克拉克（Evelyn Clark），被称为“I-70栅栏女士”，多年来用彩色杯子在栅栏上放置各种信息，给高速公路的司机们带来了无尽的欢乐。从生日快乐到毕业快乐再到节日快乐，多年来伊芙琳向许许多多的人送去了祝福。尽管伊芙琳现在已经搬离了那个房子，但圣查尔斯的所有居民都知道究竟是哪一段栅栏会在他们的旅途中为他们送上美好的祝愿。啊。我太喜欢那些给社区带来这样快乐的人了。
Me too. It is a treasure. You are a treasure. And you just don't even realize how many people's lives
you impact. All those people, it becomes part of like their travel lore, you know, they drive by,
they want to see what the sign is. It's just special. It is. There was this house that was like in the
section of Manchester, Missouri, where I lived, which is a suburb of St. Louis. And these folks painted
their house bright purple. And I swear, I think I've even talked about this on the podcast before.
But it was the purple house. And we loved their purple house. Everyone knew the purple house. You could
give directions. You could be like, oh, you know the Dairy Queen by the Purple House.
Yes, of course. I know exactly where I am right now.
我也是。这是一个宝藏。你就是一个宝藏。你甚至没有意识到你影响了多少人的生活。所有这些人，它变成了他们旅行传说的一部分，你知道的，他们开车经过，想要看看标语是什么。这真的很特别。确实如此。在密苏里州曼彻斯特我住过的那片区域，有一栋房子，那是圣路易斯的郊区。这些人把他们的房子刷成了亮紫色。我发誓，我想我以前甚至在播客里谈论过这个。但它就是那栋紫色的房子。我们都很喜欢他们的紫色房子。每个人都知道紫色房子。你可以给人指路，你可以说，哦，你知道紫色房子旁边的冰雪皇后（Dairy Queen）吗？对，当然。我完全知道我现在在哪里。
Yeah.
And I like it when people get a little quirky in their communities.
I do too. There was this house that went all out for Easter.
They decorated their yard with all of these giant bunnies.
I don't even know where they got them because they were like made out of wood and hand-painted.
It looked like they made them.
And then they had some kind of oversized Easter eggs.
And we as kids would get so excited to drive by the bunny house at Easter and see the big bunny.
对。我喜欢人们在他们的社区里表现得有点古怪的时候。我也是。曾有这样一栋房子，为了复活节可以说是全情投入。他们在院子里装饰了所有这些巨大的兔子。我甚至不知道他们是从哪里弄来的，因为它们看起来像是木头做的，而且是手绘的。看起来像是他们自己做的。然后他们还有一些超大的复活节彩蛋。我们小时候在复活节开车路过兔子屋看到大兔子时会兴奋得不得了。
We've got a guy in our neighborhood now who does blowups at the holidays.
Oh, I know it.
I know the house.
You know it.
Yeah.
Every year they add a new one.
Every year you're like, what have we added this year?
They have some that are taller than their house, but I don't even know where they're going
我们现在社区里有个家伙，每逢节假日就会摆放充气玩偶。哦，我知道。我认识那栋房子。你知道的。对。他们每年都会添加一个新的。每年你都会想，今年我们又添了什么？有些甚至比他们的房子还要高，我甚至不知道他们还要把它们
to put more.
They are out of room.
It is stacked.
But it's so fun to drive by.
It's so fun to drive by.
And, you know, my kids will always remember that.
Yeah.
That's going to be a core memory for them.
摆在哪里。他们已经没有空间了。堆得满满的。但开车路过真的很有趣。开车路过太有趣了。而且，你知道，我的孩子们会永远记住这一点。对。这将成为他们核心记忆的一部分。
Absolutely.
And when they have kids, they're going to be excited to bring them over here for Christmas
because they're going to get to drive by the house with all the blowups.
Well, listen, folks, we've got one last around the town for you.
It's from Page R and Bethany Z.
They both wrote in with this important update from Richmond, Virginia.
Ooh.
Quote, there's an update on the big deal dog.
绝对是的。当他们有了孩子，他们会很高兴在圣诞节时把孩子们带到这里来，因为他们可以开车路过摆满充气玩偶的房子。好吧，各位，我们为你们准备了最后一个“走访小镇”的内容。它来自佩奇·R（Page R）和贝瑟尼·Z（Bethany Z）。他们俩都写信提供了来自弗吉尼亚州里士满的这个重要最新消息。哦。引用一下：“关于大号热狗（big deal dog）有最新消息了。”
Remember we talked about that big deal dog, lady?
I remember.
Well, the Richmond flying squirrels were so psyched about the shoutings.
out on the podcast that they put out a poll to the community asking if they should bring back
the big deal dog. Richmond voted and the squirrels just announced the return of the big deal dog to their
menu. Thank you both for helping us bring back one of Richmond's iconic ballpark snacks. Hey, how about that?
Well, now I feel like we have to go. We have to go. And we have to eat this big deal dog.
I know. And we might tell Frey, it's one of our new favorite lunches. We might.
还记得我们谈论过那个大号热狗吗，女士？我记得。好吧，里士满飞松鼠队（Richmond Flying Squirrels）对在播客中被提及感到非常兴奋，以至于他们在社区里发起了一项投票，询问是否应该把大号热狗重新带回菜单。里士满人投票了，松鼠队刚刚宣布大号热狗重返他们的菜单。谢谢你们俩帮助我们找回了里士满标志性的棒球场小吃之一。嘿，觉得怎么样？好吧，现在我觉得我们必须去了。我们必须去。而且我们必须吃这个大号热狗。我知道。而且我们可能会告诉弗雷（Frey），这是我们最喜欢的新午餐之一。我们可能会的。
All right. Well, finally, our office question of the week is from Meeha W in Poland, who said,
there is an official Lego set depicting the office. Do you own one? And what is it like to be a mini figure?
I have one. I have one as well. Jenna, you got it first, so you should share.
I asked for it for Christmas.
Mm-hmm. Like, I got it for Christmas from Lee, because I was so excited. What is it like to be a mini-figure?
I mean, my gosh, we've gone to Lego land multiple times.
We love Lego.
So this was thrilling.
好吧，最后，我们本周的办公室问题来自波兰的米哈·W（Meeha W），他问：有一款描绘《办公室》的官方乐高套装。你们拥有一个吗？成为一个小人仔是什么感觉？我有一个。我也有一个。詹娜，你是先拿到它的，所以你应该分享一下。我是把它当作圣诞礼物要的。嗯哼。就像，我从李（Lee）那里得到了它作为圣诞礼物，因为我太激动了。成为一个小人仔是什么感觉？我的天哪，我们去过好多次乐高乐园了。我们喜欢乐高。所以这太让人兴奋了。
I mean, how many Lego have I put together?
How many organizational systems have I created in my home for stray Lego?
How many?
Hours have I stepped on.
So many.
I mean, right?
You have kids.
我是说，我拼过多少乐高？我在家里为散落的乐高创建了多少个收纳系统？有多少？我踩到过多少次。太多了。太多了。我是说，对吧？你有孩子。
You have Legos, period.
I mean, how many ships have we put together?
Oh, my goodness.
So many, like, boats and planes and, you know,
You know what? Cade and Josh did the Lego that's the whole entire globe, you know?
Oh, yeah.
That is like tons of pieces. And we have little tiny, organized drawers of different parts.
And anyway, Legos are a huge part of our lives. We were all thrilled as castmates from the office.
你就有乐高，句号。我是说，我们拼过多少艘船？哦，天哪。好多，比如船只和飞机，还有，你知道的。你知道吗？凯德（Cade）和乔希（Josh）拼了那个整个地球仪的乐高，你知道吗？哦，对。那有成千上万个零件。我们有不同零件的小型分类抽屉。不管怎样，乐高是我们生活中很大的一部分。作为《办公室》的演员伙伴，我们都兴奋不已。
We all talked about it. I think it was on our little text thread. I mean, this was a super cool moment.
I loved putting it together. The detail is really great.
and it just took me back.
I mean, there's a Michael's office, and then there's the whole bullpen.
And it was so fun because you don't like put all the mini figures together.
They're in different bags.
So you'll open a new bag, and there's two new little people in there, which is very fun.
I loved it.
我们都谈论过这件事。我想它在我们的群聊里出现过。这是一个非常酷的时刻。我很享受拼它的过程。细节真的很好，它一下子把我带回了过去。我是说，那里有迈克尔的办公室，然后是整个大办公室。这太有趣了，因为你不是把所有的小人仔放在一起。它们在不同的袋子里。所以你会打开一个新袋子，里面有两个新的小人仔，这非常有趣。我太喜欢了。
It was great.
Well, I didn't have one lady, but I was at the office fan convention, and I got to meet J.J. Lewis.
And you guys at the convention and our office fans, you will know that he was a fan creator who originally pitched and designed this office Lego set.
Yes, this is a thing.
They have a thing called like Lego ideas and you can submit this is how the Friends Lego set came about as well.
Yeah, there's an interview on the actual Lego website.
I will put a link to it and it talks about where he's from.
and there's a picture of him, and he sort of talks about his journey designing this.
太棒了。好吧，女士，我本来没有一个，但我在办公室粉丝见面会上见到了J·J·刘易斯（J.J. Lewis）。你们在见面会上以及我们的办公室粉丝们会知道，他是一位粉丝创作者，最初构思并设计了这款办公室乐高套装。是的，有这么个东西。他们有一个叫做“乐高创意（Lego Ideas）”的项目，你可以提交设计，这也是《老友记》乐高套装的诞生方式。是的，在乐高官方网站上有一个采访。我会放一个链接，里面谈到了他是哪里人，还有他的照片，他大致讲述了自己设计这个产品的历程。
And I got to meet him, and he gave me a box, and he signed it.
So I didn't open it because I was so thrilled to have this from him.
And it says that the official set was brought to life by Lego designers Chris Perrin and
Laura Perrin and senior graphic designer Diego Sancho.
So I want to give them a shout out as well.
But what a wonderful collaboration that started with J.J. Lewis's vision.
Oh, that's super cool.
Yeah.
我见到了他，他给了我一个盒子，并在上面签名了。所以我没有打开它，因为我太高兴能从他那里得到这个了。上面写着这个官方套装是由乐高设计师克里斯·佩林（Chris Perrin）、劳拉·佩林（Laura Perrin）和高级平面设计师迭戈·桑cho（Diego Sancho）共同实现的。所以我也想向他们致敬。但这是一个多么美好的合作，始于J·J·刘易斯的愿景。哦，太酷了。对。
Well, listen, everyone.
We hope you enjoyed this episode.
Thank you for joining us.
We love this community.
It means so much that you show up each week to listen to us chit-chat and share our office memories.
Yeah, thank you guys so much.
We love chatting with you.
Please write us.
好吧，各位。希望你们喜欢这一集。感谢你们加入我们。我们热爱这个社区。你们每周都出现收听我们的闲聊并分享我们的办公室记忆，这对我们意义重大。是的，非常感谢你们！我们喜欢和你们聊天。请给我们写信。
I'll put links in our stories to everything.
And we hope you have a great day.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher.
and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle,
and our audio engineer is Sam Keefer.
我会在我们的快拍中放置指向一切的链接。希望你们度过美好的一天。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
Music
Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Ruppertry》。音乐